well it's just one start for jackson
color his eighth of the year but a good
one today really could help him as he
goes into the off-season and gets ready
for next year
and buxton
cracking one down the line to left and
arise will go to third buxton to second
base
and the twins are off for a good start
here with a pair of base hits to start
the first inning so two on nobody out
and here comes jorge polanco
and a drive to right field hit to the
gap way back and go on a three-run home
run
jorge polanco now has 98 runs batted in
and he's jump started the twins to a
three-nothing lead
well rise went up there he was
aggressive swung at the first pitch
polanco goes up there he gets himself in
the heart of the zone and
got just enough of it to hit it 404 feet
but as you said only now two rbi short
of a hundred
so now sano will bat with two men aboard
and nobody out
get hard down the line and a base hit
donaldson will score it's four to
nothing
and on his way to third safely is kepler
so the
inning starts with five hits and a walk
and a quick four nothing lead still
nobody out
and there's the first out of this first
inning and here comes nick gordon
i know you're laughing but
there's a roller to short
they'll get one
but not two and
hustling down the line staying out of
the double play has allowed the fifth
run to score
charlie barnes as we said looking for
his first major league win got to be a
good feeling taking him out with a
five-nothing lead but he still has to
pitch his game
and two down for salvi
boy he's got a lot on his shoulders
hopefully he can just relax and and
see the ball
and that's inside for a walk not what
the fans wanted but that's another
career high for salvi
and a strikeout of dozier stranding a
couple of kansas city runners
nothing twins after one
so two on two out with merrifield at the
plate
[Applause]
to right field
and the royals leave two more on in
inning number two it's still five
nothing twins as we go to the third
a one for one or one for two day will
get it back to 300.
[Applause]
now
and nikki lopez beats it for a hit yes
oh
oh on contact it looked like it was
going to be soft enough and when snow
came off the back to field it nikki
lopez says i'm going to run for my life
in my 300 batting average beat it by a
half a step
oh yes
so that gets him right
at 300
and he will come out kyle isbell will go
into the game
and with that nikki lopez is the first
shortstop
in royals history to finish the season
for the 300 average
santana is the batter two on nobody out
line base hit left field isbell to third
he'll be waved home
and rooker's throw will be cut off and
the royals are on the board
a change up you know that's
it's a good pitch to hit when it's over
the plate but when it's off the plate
you get a lot of swinging misses on that
isabel no trouble coming home and
getting the royals on the board
so first and third with two out now
monday runs the throw goes down to
second and it's going to roll into
center field
and ryan jeffers just gave the royals a
run
that was not a wise throw in a four-run
game
especially with mondissey's jump so it's
5-2 and monday ends up at third base
we always have a chance for a nice
inning here
grounded left side
gordon will throw on a bounce not in
time
monday scores and the royals have three
in the third inning
of the ball right now and that's byron
buxton that ball is crushed down the
left field line and i mean crushed and
it hits off the foul pole and i believe
that's going to be a two run over
and the twins are up
seven to three that got out of here in a
hurry he hit that ball country mile
right there it was just whether it was
going to stay fair foul or whether he
was going to run on a foul pole
if it was going to go over dylan coleman
will get the sixth inning
and a slider
183
strikeouts
wow
back-to-back strikeouts beautiful
center field and taylor will make the
play on nick gordon and the twins go
down in order against coleman in the
sixth
bear club come in try to do what the
bullpen has done a nice job of once
again today a short start by charlie
barnes taken out in the third and the
bullpen hasn't given the royals anything
to work with
fort myers swing and a miss and down
goes mirror field goal for four two
strikeouts
and a cold third strike and here comes
salvi we hope
not for the last time that there's two
down in the seventh inning
and he didn't want that swing but he's
down on strikes
and bear claw strikes out the side the
royals have two on with nobody out
monday bunts in the air
and it's going to be caught
two and two
all right fastball gets a swing and a
miss two away full count to o'hern
if he reaches the tying run comes to the
plate and alkalo with the slider strikes
him out upstairs
a couple left aboard and we head to the
ninth
and the most important thing i think
that all the royals are thinking right
now is somebody get on base so we can
get salvador perez one more plate
appearance
the ball lifted to left
and heading back is gordon put it away
one down
and whit is down on strikes he goes over
five today and strikes out in his last
three at bats
and with that the 61st season
of twins baseball comes to a close
alcala saves a 7-3 win